Loads of fans, myself included, have been
absolutely loving Mamma Mia: Here We Go Again,
though something that has disappointed some
is Meryl Streep's miniscule role in the movie.
Yippee-ki-yay movie lovers, it's Jan here
and in this video, I'm going to reveal the
real reason why we see so little Streep in
the sequel and I'll also explain the behind-the-scenes
decisions that led to that scene with Donna.
Be aware there are spoilers ahead for Donna's
story in Mamma Mia 2 if you haven't seen it
yet.
When the first trailer for Mamma Mia: Here
We Go Again dropped, speculation ran wild
that Donna was no longer alive.
While Meryl Streep's appearance was teased
in some bits of new footage, the overall tone
suggested Donna had passed away.
Indeed, Sophie addresses her mother's absence
right at the start of the new movie, and it's
revealed soon after that Donna has died.
I'm glad the filmmakers ripped off that Band-Aid
instead of making us wait to find out Donna's
fate, though it did make for a somewhat melancholy
tone in some of the present-day scenes, and
it's a little frustrating we got no explanation
as to what happened.
We do, of course, get a brilliant prequel
story with Lily James as the young Donna,
but Meryl Streep herself doesn't appear in
person until the very final scene in the chapel
where she's a ghostly apparition only seen
by her daughter and then she also performs
in the Super Trouper song.
Watching Streep and Amanda Seyfried sing 'My
Love, My Life' in that closing scene is a
very touching moment, as mother and daughter
are reunited one final time.
However, it's also heart-breaking and has
had many fans crying their eyes out at the
cinema.
So, why exactly did the filmmakers really
make this particular story choice?
Something that was kept pretty hush-hush during
the publicity tour for Mamma Mia 2 is that
Meryl Streep wasn't keen on doing a sequel.
Here We Go Again writer-director Ol Parker
has admitted that Streep's small role in the
new movie wasn't due to scheduling conflicts.
In fact, he said that if Streep had taken
the main lead role in the sequel, then the
production would have moved its schedule to
accommodate her.
After all, they waited 10 years to do Mamma
Mia 2, so I doubt another 6 or 12 months would
have mattered.
The main issue was that Streep didn't want
such a major part in any sequel.
Indeed, Mamma Mia creator Judy Craymer revealed
that Streep told her she would never take
on all that singing and running around on
clifftops again.
And that's not because she didn't enjoy making
the first movie, it's just that during her
incredible career, the three-time Oscar-winning
actress has, until now, never made a sequel.
Streep is one of Hollywood's most versatile
and successful actresses and she's rightly
willing to turn down roles if they don't peak
her interest enough.
I certainly can't fault her for wanting to
keep her career and life fresh for herself,
and let's remember, of course, that on top
of that, she's 69 now, 10 years older than
when she made the original Mamma Mia.
Still, Streep DID want "to be involved" in
the sequel in some way, so the challenge was
for the filmmakers to figure out a follow-up
story that worked with drastically less Donna.
Ol Parker who was tasked with writing the
script for Mamma Mia 2 struggled initially,
coming up empty on ideas.
Obviously, Donna isn't the only main character
in Mamma Mia, however, the core of the story
has always centred around her and her daughter
Sophie, so cutting out Donna left a big hole.
The solution eventually came from Richard
Curtis's daughter who suggested they take
a cue from one of the most famous and best-ever
movie sequels, The Godfather Part 2, in other
words, do a prequel-meets-sequel.
By writing a prequel story with a new young
cast, it meant that the much-loved character
of Donna could remain centre-stage in Mamma
Mia 2 without Streep actually appearing on
screen for most of the movie.
The original film had hinted at a rich backstory
for Donna which gave the filmmakers plenty
of ideas to explore in the Young Donna storyline.
As for how Streep's small part in the movie
would work, Ol Parker decided that the "most
meaningful and emotional and impactful way"
would be for Donna to die.
That decision was discussed with everyone
and Streep was reported to be "thrilled and
delighted" with passing the baton to the younger
cast.
Now, your feelings on whether the producers
made a good decision in killing off Donna
will vary, I'm sure.
Ol Parker himself has said that he knew the
decision would be a radical and controversial
one and that the audience would decide whether
it was "radical good or radical bad."
Donna's passing is obviously felt throughout
the movie, from Rosie bursting into tears
when her name is mentioned to Sam singing
a plaintive 'S.O.S.'
by himself in contrast to the 'S.O.S.'
duet he sang with Meryl Streep in the first
movie.
Amanda Seyfried said she thinks the sequel
is better, and called the first movie "a beach"
in comparison to Here We Go Again which she
described as "an ocean" in terms of its emotional
depth.
And, I suspect, that the slightly darker tone
and story of Mamma Mia 2 might have played
better for critics in their reviews of this
film compared to the first one.
As for me, I really enjoyed the new movie
though I have some mixed feelings.
One part of me wishes they could have figured
out a clever story that kept Donna alive and
managed to have Meryl Streep appear for at
least a few more scenes.
However, I realise that, both story-wise and
given the amount of time they had with Streep,
that would have been a rather difficult feat
to pull off, without having some overly-convoluted
reasoning for why Sophie's mother was absent.
Something that occurred to me is that in Mamma
Mia 2, young Donna's friends try to convince
her to go out and see the world rather than
stay on the island, so maybe that idea could
have worked for present-day Donna.
Despite some melancholy moments then, the
sequel is still full of charm and has lots
of joyous, celebratory scenes, culminating
in the curtain-call performance of Super Trouper
where Meryl Streep joins all the old and new
cast for a final rousing number.
Now, I'd love to know what you think about
Meryl Streep's role in the movie, so I've
added a poll where you can vote.
Just tap in the top right of this video and
after you've cast your vote, you'll be able
to see the results.
And don't forget to subscribe and leave a
comment for your chance to win one of these
awesome Mamma Mia 2 merch packs.
Remember also to click the Gleam link in the
video description below to register your entry!
Tap left to watch another Mamma Mia 2 video
or tap right for my full Mamma Mia and musicals
playlist.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!